lynn a tué à paris pour quelques jours
mais tu habites ou en général pour le
moment on vient de finir en décembre et
tourné en allemagne en suisse et en
hollande où est ce que tu te sens
vraiment chez toi je me sens chez moi
partout et surtout albi se moquer de
nous ta fille on a beaucoup entendu
parler de ta fille ya quelques années
maintenant qu'est ce qu'elle est devenue
elle a six ans et on joue aux petits
chevaux toutes les gueules
elle fait aussi du dessin comme sa maman
ça c'est un de mes dix ans c'est un
dessin tout deux filles ça c'est un
dessin moi mais ma fille fait aussi des
dessins et elle veut faire une
exposition dans une galerie avec moi on
organise plein de partie et tomba rythme
fait un merveilleux mariage était
dernier mot il est où ton mari éric toi
ici à paris mon mari tu t'es marié avec
un membre hot wheels by sa
tu veux parler du film en langue non
émis sauf des mariés dit ça non en 79
j'ai épousé herman brottes dans le film
cha cha et l'année dernière je fais un
autre film qui s'appelait spiritual punk
web
c'était une vidéo faite par la
télévision espagnole qui s'appelle
spiritual pas en quoi c'est aussi un
film c'est un film est d'un avis tu es
marié non dans la vie je ne suis pas
mariée à c'était juste un film c'était
seulement pour une vidéo mais tout le
monde pensait qu'ils étaient vraiment
marié non je ne suis pas mort tu es
libre j'aimerais que dans les films
j'aime bien qu'étant prochain album
d'inna mon prochain album
tiens regarde voilà la campagne prévue
pour mai prochain à reading ça s'appelle
wild 2 par le coup c'est la partie parce
que tout le monde veut aller avait parti
moi la première d'ailleurs la grande
question c'est donc et c'est la partie
les bonnes parties les vrais partis ça
c'est une chanteuse russe appelle à la
pulga java c'est la chanteuse numéro un
en urss
nina hagen et j'ai demandé à allah ou et
la partie et la partie va se faire à
moscou parce que c'est là que je vais
faire mon prochain album
c'est quand tu commences à enregistrer
ça commencera le mois prochain pour
aller à moscou pour enregistrer et en
mars on veut à new york pour faire le
mixage de l'album est ensuite vers avril
ou mai l'album devrait être émis sur le
marché
il est assez facile pour toi qui est né
en allemagne de l'est de retourner en
urs c'est que je suis devenu une telle
star à l'ouest et ossi halal est mon
album in-extenso par exemple se vend 300
roubles en urss mois 300 loupé ça fait
environ 1000 dollars pour acheter un
disque de nina hagen en urss
alors j'ai souri un contrat avec lui
mais l'audience a maintenant ils peuvent
vendre mes disques partout dans le monde
tu imagines combien de mairesses var
s'enrichit
c'est pas un problème pour toi il te
pardonne et être échappé c'était pas
c'était pas les russes étaient les
allemands les russes n'ont rien à voir
avec tout ça rien du tout qui leur pose
pas de problème pas du tout ils veulent
signer un contrat pour méditer nos
médias c'est la grande maison de disque
soviétique revendre mes disques dans le
monde entier melodia en urss c'est
incroyable ils sont prêts à payer des
millions je ne parle même pas bien le
russe
je parle russe à peu près aussi mal que
le français comme lyon un truc en
bouquet bien ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire je t'aime
humeur can you tu veux montrer d'autres
desseins oui bien sûr mais qu'est ce que
tu penses de cette partie
le débat c'est toi qui as fait ça je
trouve pas que c'est une partie
décadente
il se passe vraiment quelque chose de
louche voyons celui ci c'est encore une
autre partie punk et celui ci
[Musique]
ça c'est de l'autre côté
tu te rappelles quand tu t'es
là tu te souviens quand tu t'es
masturber en direct à la télé
autrichienne pour commencer maintenant
ou est ce que tu es devenu plus sage et
tu ne serais plus en fait c'est passé
comme ça j'avais mon boyfriend ferdinand
qui était un junkie et puis ferdinand
m'a fait un bébé et on peut avoir un
bébé que si on a une vie sexuelle
vraiment extatique
à ce moment là on peut avoir des bébés
tu sais et moi je veux pas d'enfant pour
le moment alors je ne peux pas
développer mon énergie sexuelle parce
que je sens que je dois montrer aux
femmes dans le moins comment avoir un
orgasme et ça vient du fond de mon coeur
maintenant en afrique ou au niger et
dans tous ces pays ya le sida et tous
ces gens qui manquent de nourriture
toutes les femmes c'est vrai je
plaisante pas les femmes ne peuvent pas
avoir d'orgasmes parce qu'elles ont été
excisées
tout le monde le sait mais c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles il faut en
parler de la liberté sexuelle c'est très
important et pour cette raison j'ai fait
ça à la télé autrichienne et après je
suis tombée enceinte et j'ai eu ma fille
au retour de la big n y est pas allé
avec before you j'ai un cadeau pour toi
c'est qu'aujourd'hui c'est la sainte
nina oh ça c'est vraiment gentil ça me
plaît beaucoup c'est vraiment gentil
répéter tu peux en manger
oui mais je vais d'abord je vais
l'offrir à dieu et je vais mettre une
figurine de krishna dessus et je vais
chanter
[Applaudissements]
ça nous fait plaisir on t'adore des
corrections de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus